360 degrees is one complete rotation and
you might think it's the same as 720
degrees or two complete rotations but
nature actually does distinguish between
the two
there are objects that are the same
after two rotations that are the same
after one these are called spinous and
the palm of your hand is one example
after one 360 degree rotation it isn't
the same but after a second lap or 720
degrees it returns to normal
a similar illustration can be done with
a belt or a long braid one end is fixed
and one can move I have a ribbon on the
back side to tell front and back apart
after one full spin there is no way to
untangle the hair without further
rotation but after another full spin 720
degrees there is now a way to return it
to how it was without rotating either
end just moving it up and across this
animation also shows the concept but
this time with mini belts and because
each belt is the same after two full
rotations the ends can spin continuously
without any becoming tangled